I still got it great serve thank you a
while ago we did a video called jello
tennis I think was the name jelly jelly
tennis probably jelly tennis because
we're from England yeah and we did it
about 2,500 FPS since then technology
has advanced we can now do 12,000 frames
a second in full HD with the b-26 40
also jelly technologies improved we've
managed to do multicolored rainbow jelly
now this technology did exist back when
we did it the first time we just
couldn't be bothered and I'm glad we
didn't do it last time cuz that took
forever it took me a week I do like 20
of these because you have to set
individual layers and each layer takes
about eight hours to set yeah so we made
a load of them because probably we're
not gonna get it every single time it's
really difficult to get the framing
right with the tennis and the jelly and
everything I think that's literally the
same tennis racket we use lost it's
still sticky from last time all right
let's get this table out the way let's
frame up the Phantom and get some lovely
shots some jelly getting cut up into
little strips I'm gonna get that jelly
out nicely this is the Phantom V 26:40
it's a liquid-cooled beast that does
twelve and a half thousand frames a
second in full HD okay
first attempt good luck
ready yeah sake
wish me luck this time
going for it I'll hit it yeah this is
good speed I like this speed that's
pretty sweet
a chunky jelly that diced oh that was
perfect look at those colors there it's
wicked oh that's so cool like that is
awesome
all those little worms so I need to be
lower okay I think looking up alright
cuz you're hitting it a lot slower than
we yeah it's because I think last time I
had it in my hand and I was loving it
yeah which meant I had more time but
because the jellies so big now yeah and
like more it matters more about the
individual colors and the colors are so
thin I'm just having to drop it out of
this which means I'm having to come up
from lower down than I was before
alright it's not under water so got like
there to back like the jelly just so
it's a little glowy went down hits it
and a pretty shoddy white background is
so not shooting against the fence
you ready Daniel yeah I'd really keep
spotting though really yeah it's like he
keeps just goofing I like splashed it in
the rim you can see the rim of the
tennis racket move I left behind some of
the colors there
go for it Oh
Yuson I lay in the back oh no I'm gonna
do I love how it goes from just being a
sort of questionable looking blob it
looks like an amoeba yeah it's like
you're hitting a rainbow egg and
suddenly a rainbow was born a sweet
bloody fool
you can see every individual color looks
like it literally looks like a rainbow
has been formed out of giant wormy rain
droplets it looks like a unicorn sneeze
I would hate to be on the bottom of that
you'd see all the stuff I'm sorry should
I hold it down or something no it's only
it's like a it's just so we're not
looking at offense it doesn't have to be
too clean therefore slightly trickier
shot changing our focal length so like
sort of that which drastically shrinks
the window that makes both of our jobs
much harder yes I've been struggling to
hit properly with the wide yeah now the
rest of these jellies are pretty much
gonna be used to try and get it so that
upon me I can get it right in frame on
the tight
missed off of it all right you got this
come on
oh so odd
Oh damnit
[Music]
all right let's check this one out take
48 bit of a flaw pitch coming down yeah
all right so the jury's a bit yeah oh
it's just in the racket it's a
multicolored wormy wow it's so difficult
because not only it's like half of its
down to chance yeah because the jelly
has to be spinning at the right place to
get the colours in the right area and I
have to hit it exactly in the middle of
the racket exactly the right time all
right now while Don gets another gel I
flip the entire set up 180 because the
Sun is now low enough where it's
perfectly backlighting these jellies and
Dan's definitely gonna get on this one
aren't you down oh yeah yeah okay we go
I think it was good I think it was good
I think I did all right let's take a
look at it all right
so the background is a lot darker
because yeah it's hard to see what's
even going on here shove your face right
in see now oh yeah there's a bit of the
orange jell-o coming down here he comes
here he comes
Oh Deluxe that's absolutely luscious
here we come come on nail it
oh yeah as well cool as well been wicked
I was perfectly like each jet each
little eel had every color in it it's
rainbow eel very nice work and a lot of
them a lot the lower ones they all go
from being long worms to curling the
exact same way it's really weird isn't
it how does that happen
all I'm doing is hitting it with a
racquet see it was nice the last time in
it but now is like fascinatingly nice
because you can see exactly what's going
on
I love the backlight I think that's the
best decision how many more we got that
was the last normal one who collect yeah
we got the last one even though that was
incredibly time-consuming and
frustrating to shoot I feel like we've
got the cream that we wanted honestly I
think the backlit shot was worth it
alone yeah that was just so cool looking
the way it looks sweet with the jelly
see-through and everything so it was
just one of those shots you look at and
you just think oh that's nice like I
like looking at this good come to think
of it that video is taking us for me
about 15 hours of jelly making hitting
things I like a bad back now I'm like I
just been stood there today okay oh now
you need to sit down wait to sit down oh
well hopefully you enjoyed that lovely
little revisit much slower revisit feel
free to follow us on Instagram and all
that we got a second channel and we'll
put out another video pretty damn soon
thanks for watching